bonjour tout le monde jeudi passé
gouvernement déposé un projet de loi sur
la laïcité de l'état
j'ai envie de dire enfin c'est un débat
qui 2 depuis plus de dix ans il est
temps qu'un gouvernement met en place
des règles claires pour tout le monde
notre projet de loi prévoit que les
signes religieux vont maintenant être
interdit pour les employés de l'état en
position d'autorité par exemple les
policiers les gardiens de prison et les
enseignants des écoles primaires et
secondaires faut être clair la laïcité
vopos à l'encontre de la liberté de
religion chacun vaut rester libres de
pratiquer la religion de son choix mais
faut fixer des règles et c'est ça qu'on
fait c'est une approche qui respecte
notre histoire nos valeurs et c'est une
approche qui respecte ce que souhaite
une grande majorité des québécois et
pour rassembler le plus de québécois
possible
on a fait un compromis en ajoutant une
clause droits acquis pour les employés
qui sont déjà en fonction
certains m'ont dit qu'on va trop loin
d'autres vont dire qu'on va pas assez
loin
en réalité ce projet de loi est modéré
comme le sont les québécois
ce projet de loi précise aussi que les
services publics vont devoir être donnée
à visage découvert et toute personne qui
reçoit un service public va devoir se
découvrir le visage pour s'identifier ou
pour des raisons de sécurité pour éviter
des longues batailles juridiques on a
décidé d'utiliser la clause dérogatoire
dès l'adoption du projet de loi
c'est un outil légitime que déjà été
utilisée par rené lévesque et par robert
bourassa au québec ça fait longtemps
qu'on a décidé de séparer la religion et
l'état et ça fait plus de dix ans qu'on
déborde des signes religieux
il est temps de fixer des règles parce
qu'au québec c'est comme ça qu'on vit
merci